hi I'm Nick Gillespie with Reason TV
today I'm talking to David Eagleman a
professor at Baylor Medical School David
thanks for talking to me thanks you do a
lot on neuroscience and the law what's
your basic research project the basic
idea is to understand how modern
neuroscience affects the way we think
about criminal behavior and new ideas
for criminal punishment and
rehabilitation and even how jurors make
decisions so I'm trying to this is where
our understanding neuroscience this is
where the rubber hits the road where we
see how that makes sense for society to
have evidence-based policy and
evidence-based legal system what is the
single biggest contribution that
neuroscience can bring to a better
criminal justice system or practice I
think there are a few areas one of them
is going to be introducing new ideas for
rehabilitation for example we know that
one of the things that characterizes
most criminal behavior is very poor
impulse control
so most criminals can tell you in a
moment of sober reflection what the
right and wrong thing to do is they just
have very bad impulse control that's a
place where we can actually help using
cutting-edge technologies in a
libertarian fashion that allows people
to help themselves by strengthening the
long term decision making parts of their
brain that's one example another example
is having rational sentencing by
understanding how likely someone is to
reoffended basing the length of their
sentence on that this is already in use
in courtrooms with essentially
statistical or actuarial tests and we're
using neuroscience to try to improve
those even more we'll never have 100%
correlation because life is much too
complicated for that but at least we can
distinguish who's a really bad seed that
we want to lock away for a long time
versus people who might not be in can
use the shorter prison sentence you talk
about the kind of libertarian sentiment
or the idea the individual can be more
in control of themselves yet at the same
time does the does the basis of
neuroscience almost completely erode or
at least seriously challenge another
basic political
BIRT aryan idea about autonomy or about
the idea that we are actually in control
of our actions or ourselves I'm afraid
it does the understanding from
neuroscience that's very clear by
looking at examples of brain damage or
disease or stroke or epilepsy things
like that or drugs is that you are your
biology and when the biology changes
that changes you and people who
otherwise behaved in man or X you change
their brain somehow and they behave in
man or Y so all of this has taught us
over a long period of time that maybe
we're not the ones driving the boat to
the extent that we into it and of course
people have been debating the freewill
question for a very long time I think
it's very difficult to come down on one
side of the other and answer whether we
do or don't have free will but what I'm
pretty certain about now is that to
whatever extent we have free will it's
really only a bit player in what
actually happens in people's lives so is
this a rien scription of Freud was
famous for saying that you know the I
guess the super-ego kind of rides the
the it or the ego rides the it and it
kind of directs it sort of like a horse
gets direct wild horse gets directed by
a driver I mean is this a scientifically
more sound or more credible at least at
this point in time version of Freud
that's exactly right
Freud got some things right and wrong
but what he got really right was this
idea that most of your drives and
instincts are completely inaccessible to
you they are the subconscious
we're not acquainted with those drives
and instead of it being like a rider on
a horse it's more like you're a little
stowaway on a battleship the conscious
brain just doesn't have that much
influence over who you are and so when
you look at a criminal and you say well
that guy I wouldn't have done that we
should we should make that guy hurt
because he made a bad freewheel decision
it's not clear that that's it's not
clear that your brain of his brain are
anything alike one thing that's very
important is this does not exculpatory
develop a better biological
understanding it does not let anyone off
the hook instead we're still going to
lock people away but it allows us to do
rational sentencing to introduce new
ideas rehabilitation and better
understand how do you incentivize how to
structure incentives in the society so
that's the goal of a biological
understanding what you know what are the
implications for say a free-market
economy I mean if we're not really in
control of our decision-making process
or our behavior you know can you have a
free enterprise system which is based on
rational or you know semi rational
actors pursuing their self-interest so
it's pretty clear now that humans are
not rational in their decision-making
but they are study Abal and we can
understand how people make decisions one
of the important points that often gets
overlooked is that there's a real
spectrum in the population along any
axis that you measure so some people
will make pretty rational economic
decisions other people make very
terrible intuitive decisions and I think
the important end goal for us and trying
to structure economies and structure a
legal system is to understand what the
population actually looks like and how
they actually behave obviously as a you
know as a scientific community we've
long ago given up the idea that we
understand people as rational actors
because that's not the case as we
understand what they actually are we'll
be able to structure things pretty
nicely what would you say to people who
say look you know this just sounds like
you know a version of a kind of 60s
liberal mollycoddling of criminals you
know where you're saying oh they didn't
do it they're jeans that if their brain
did it their addiction did it here's
what I would say because we know the
complexity of gene-environment
interactions there's no way that we'll
ever be able to say oh it's their genes
or we're not gonna be able to identify
the root of it so my suggestion is what
we need is a completely forward-looking
legal system we need to understand the
human brain better so that we can say
given the brain that's in front of the
judges bench right now what do we do
with it from here forward given all the
data we have from the past about people
who have similar brains what do we do
with it now so it's not coddling because
we're still putting people away what we
are doing is we're not using
incarceration as the blunt tool that it
is currently used as so instead of
throwing everybody in jail with
previously mandated sentences we're able
to modify it on an individual basis but
people wait for longer shorter time
we're able to introduce new ideas to
rehabilitation which you
very important take something like the
drug war we spent hundreds of billions
of dollars attacking the supply which
has shown itself to be a failure in
every way what we should be doing is
addressing the demand drug addiction is
a real problem but we can address the
addicts brain we can use rehabilitation
there it's not a matter of coddling a
drug addict it's a matter of fixing the
problem
saving our society trillions of dollars
and a lot of human misery you have also
you've published an incredibly
well-received the fictional meditation
on the afterlife some can you talk a
little bit about the book and where did
that come from so some is literary
fiction and it's 40 mutually exclusive
short stories and they all purport to
take place in different possible after
lives the key is that they're all
mutually exclusive the reason I wrote
this book it's because you know I've
devoted my life to science but at some
point the toolbox of science runs out
and beyond the edge of that is
everything that we don't know and I've
always thought the afterlife is an
interesting example where people act
like they know one way or the other
what's going on they say we die there's
no afterlife they say there's an
afterlife with clouds and angels all
right and the funny part is everyone's
making it up and acting like they have
certainty about something so I wrote a
book where it's 40 stories that are all
mutually exclusive all the stories are
mischievous and funny but what serious
about the book is the meta message which
is that it's a celebration of our
ignorance it's a way of shining a
flashlight around the possibility space
to say you know in fact we know nothing
about any of this you believe in an
afterlife oh I have no idea you have no
idea if you believe one way or the other
no reason to believe in any particular
afterlife or if there is one it's always
great to have scientists talk about the
limits of knowledge when we talk about
science and its intersection with the
law it's a pretty unsavory history right
you know pre-fund prefrontal lobotomies
or psychiatric controls on people a
pretty ugly history and it it always
seems that scientists are absolutely
secure that the knowledge they have at
this point in time is truly scientific
and it's not culturally constructed at
some pies how do you guard against the
you know that kind of self delusion that
seems to attend to a lot of past the
scientific interventions into society
yeah it's a very important question I
think in general
scientists are and have been pretty
smart about trying not to scream ahead
of their moral compass on these sorts of
things and that was true with the
prefrontal lobotomy as it was with with
development of nuclear arms I mean the
scientists were at the forefront of
developing that became the people who
were at the forefront of the movements
to limit nuclear proliferation so I
think sciences in general are sort of
smart about trying to be cautious about
this stuff what I like about the
rehabilitation methods that I'm working
on right now is they've got tremendous
libertarian appeal because they are only
offering methods for someone to change
themselves someone to tip the balance of
the battle between their long-term
decision-making and their impulses so it
allows you to be a better decision maker
it's not the government going in and
doing some sort of psycho surgery on you
it's you if you choosing to learning how
to defer gratification for longer term
strategy
David thanks for talking to us we've
been talking with David Eagleman a
bailer
and the author of the wonderful book
some new cholesky for reason to big
you